i am also in a space where i just don't
care to distract with i don't know i'm
just like living life
and whatever happens happens but i'm not
like thinking about i'm not putting my
energy there so
that was kourtney kardashian talking
about dating back in 2019
but now a source tells et that the
reality star is dating her longtime
friend
travis barker i don't think we do dates
or blind dates
i don't mind dating but and i met
tristan on a blank date so i do both you
are not a good dater
no i just get uncomfortable like friends
group
settings okay you want to do a group
date we just gotta find the guys
quote courtney and travis have had a
platonic relationship for years
and they've been friends and family
friends for a very long time
but recently something sparked in their
relationship has turned romantic
the source adds that the two live on the
same block
and things are quote super easy between
them they know each other so well
and just click and get one another
and et source says that her kids and his
kids
get along really well too which is a
major plus for both of them
oh my gosh am i the only one who's
totally here for this
courtney barker okay seriously no rush
but these two are totally giving me the
feels
thank you the 41 year olds keeping up
with the kardashians star and the 45
year old blink 182 drummer
first had fans talking about a potential
love connection
when they appeared to be spending some
quality time together at kris jenner's
home in palm springs
california both court and travis
shared the same poolside views on their
insta stories
i love it oh and they've been super
flirty
on instagram last week travis commented
on this sexy mere selfie with
a single rose emoji earlier this month
he also weighed in on this pick of court
in the ocean
by posting a mermaid emoji and when the
pooch founder
shared an image of the kissing scene
from the movie true romance
he hit up the comments to write you're
so cool
oh and court she's been sliding into the
comments too
on travis's tattoo post on new year's
eve this is insane
travis has two children
seventeen-year-old landon and
fifteen-year-old alabama
whom he shares with his ex-wife shayna
mulkler
court shares three children
eleven-year-old mason eight-year-old
penelope
and six-year-old reign with her ex scott
disick
i'm just decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there
and while courtney and scott ended their
nine-year relationship back
in 2015 they've managed to successfully
co-parent
i mean i think we've been through so
much in so many things and to hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
me and sometimes they even keep
fans guessing about the status of their
relationship with some
flirty af comments on instagram
like last month when scott praised court
captioning this family pic
quote thank you kourtney kardashian for
being the best baby maker in town
i couldn't have asked for a better
person in the world to have these
amazing children with
i love you and our family more than
anything in the world
you